to be on set and see someone's like
power you served sort of yeah to see
there were scenes that were literally
there was an actor that had makeup on
that he wanted to do and the director
wanted to do and one of the producers
found it offensive
she was like a devout christian and she
was offended by the makeup and she made
them reshoot that scene
um there are other times where one of
the producers who was out of town
doing probably a film market or
something because he was more like a
he was he had directed stuff in the past
but he was really more of a money guy
he came down toward the end and decided
he wanted to direct the movie
so there were parts of that movie where
the director was sort of
literally sidelined and that other guy
was calling action
and this type of stuff happens all the
time
but for me seeing that it was it was
eye-opening yeah for sure
without mentioning any names did you
ever see people set up to fail
where you could tell like oh they gave
this person like a bad
opportunity and now someone else is
going to come and look like the hero
without naming it i don't think i've
seen that that level of like you know
manipulation going on or overthinking
i've just seen directors
i mean it's happened to me but i've seen
it on a lot of films before you know i
started directing where
it was almost like they were they were
just being cut off at the knees
you know like there'd be we'd be
shooting like we did a film in romania
and
they just decided at one point they just
decided they stopped sending film stock
they like you know
had a delay i think i forget what
happened but it was some kind of a delay
in the delivery of film
a film negative and yet they weren't
going to necessarily give him extra days
to shoot you know the schedule wasn't
going to get longer you're just going to
you know
lose days because you didn't have film
delivered well
what do you expect you know what do you
expect from
those type of situation but so you know
i see people get put in situations where
it's like
you know what do you what do you think's
going to come out of this you know it's
not going to be good you're cutting your
own movie off basically but
i've seen that i've seen that time and
time again and i've seen that plenty of
times on things i've directed too
usually what it does what it is is if
anything it's producers who are lazy who
just figure well the director cares more
about this movie than i do
so i'm just not going to show up today
or
i'll show up for half the day or they
can just do whatever they can just you
know
manage it and guess what yeah we are
going to manage it because we do care
and we want the movie to come out well
so that's the kind of
that's i don't know if you call those
mind games i think it's sometimes it's
just more like laziness but there is a
little bit of a mind game going on there
because you
you're doing that knowing that the
person is gonna
you know pick up the slack you know
do you let on that you know that or do
you try to carry on like everything's
great
and then hopefully it becomes great i
probably
initially carried on more and didn't say
anything and then there are other times
where i flat i would tell them
what i thought you know i mean and
that's why
like this one producer that i did a lot
of movies for
i just stopped working with him after a
while because i just couldn't
i couldn't take it anymore i just
couldn't take but that and many other
things
ladies actually laziness and competence
i can take more than like
meanness and name calling and personal
attacks and things like that
sure um but yeah you do get to a point
where you because you really are
partners in this i mean if you're making
a move if you're directing a movie
you know essentially on a lower budget
thing where usually we have a producer
and a director
let's just simplify things as far as i'm
concerned you're partners in that
it you know i mean when you're on set it
doesn't really matter who raised the
money or who's going to supervise
post or what when you're there making a
movie you should be equal partners in
that
and you know and by that
by that same standard you know if
they're not doing no not pulling their
weight or they're
making it hard on you you have the right
to call them out on that
so so if if
a let's say a new director is in a
similar situation
it's their first time experiencing that
and they've heard about this
that maybe they will be overthrown for
on their
on their set what's the best way to
handle it and still kind of preserve
their name
i mean if you've got people doing things
behind the scenes
that are trying to get somebody removed
which we've
actually just saying that made me think
of another situation not on something i
directed but something she and i both
worked on joseph and i both worked on
that was definitely going on um being
set up to fail
i don't know i think you just have to
carry on until you know
and especially if it's your first movie
or second movie or whatever you're just
trying to
get some films completed and have a
track record as a
director i think you need to try to keep
it
even keel as much as you possibly can
you know because i do know a lot of
people by the same token i know a lot of
people have made one movie
and that's it because of you know
whatever
temperament issues or blowouts or things
that didn't go well and it just turned
into such a fireball that
that was it for them there's a lot of
people like that too
you know and they wanted to make more
films but they're not gonna because it
just blew up so much
so i think you have to try to keep it
keep a lid on it as much as you possibly
can
i don't know i think everyone everyone
has their own personal
gauge of that well some people are great
at being politicians and they like you
know
the game someone's playing and they can
still just be smooth
back and make sure they and other people
i think where they're hard on their
sleeve or they're just
more like no i'm gonna call bs when i
see it i'm just gonna like i i was
suffering
yeah i was definitely not doing that i
mean you know you'd have to feel like
you know you
for example i did a film this was a
problem with the dp
not with the producer with the dp
sometimes dps can
try to take over movies and be very
bullying because they know they have the
power especially if they have their own
camera package and everything that can
happen sometimes
and i did one movie where you know the
dp was really pulling
you know he was he was just making it
clear that he was
you know gonna make determine a lot of
things about when we're going to stop
start and stop and how much they're
going to do and this and that and
i really kept my mouth shut through the
entire process because
i had a friend who had money in that
film you know a personal friend
i had more or less some money in the
movie at that point
and i really cared a lot about that
movie and i wanted to preserve it and
complete it
so a lot of times you will just
i was not wearing my heart on my sleeve
for my first few years of
directing i think later on yeah i'll
start to
make more you know comment more on
things that aren't working
right or whatever but yeah it's
interesting how managing egos is such
like an important skill in adult life
that you
no school really prepares you for well
you know well you know the best way to
put it is like like josephine and i both
say this like on the movies we're doing
now we're in charge but like
you can say you're in charge but at the
end of the day you're really trying to
to get the best out of everyone and work
with everyone
and do what's best for the movie so
really the movie's in charge
you know and the movie's in charge i
mean and that's the same with the one i
just mentioned in the desert i mean
what's really important the movie
that's the most important thing so is it
about
telling somebody to their face what you
think about them either privately or
publicly or is it about completing the
movie and then moving on to the next
project
because you can always do another movie
and then you can work with somebody else
next time
that's usually how you handle those type
of situations
and we've both gotten try to become more
and more diplomatic over time
we try to learn from our experiences and
you know
just you know kind of keep the diplomacy
as much as you possibly can until it
just
absolutely is obviously not working but
even that's usually more of like a slow
fade than a
than a big explosion with most people
you know so i like that the movie's in
charge
it is it's the most important thing and
it looks nice people do crazy things
because of that
you know sometimes people put their
lives in danger and other people's lives
in danger
because of that directors get huge egos
the movements i mean i
i know i'm i see it from all different
angles and especially since we've been
executive producing things lately we are
on the other side of the table
so we see it even more from that
perspective which is interesting
uh but yeah the movie ultimately that
does need to be the main thing
everyone's
working toward and if some other people
don't care about it and they're gonna
quit or they're gonna
you know do whatever well you know what
you still need to complete it and and
to the best of your ability you still
need to finish it and for
for your own sake and for the film's
sake you know
so relax the movie's in charge yeah yeah
it is i mean it really is you know and
it's going to do what it's going to do
later on too you know it's going to
every film is going to you know however
much how
hard you work on it it's all going to
have they're all going to have their own
path
and their own success or lack of success
or exposure
or fandom or lack of interest or
whatever you just never know
you really never know anybody who thinks
that who says they know is
is lying you know yeah and i know it's a
very
sort of dark place for for anybody who
completes something i'm sure it's the
same for a book as well
that like okay it's done and now like
the reactions are going to be what it's
going to be and then be a very dark
place oh yeah
i mean we're we're at that place right
now not a dark place thankfully but
we're in that place right now where
we're getting our first reviews for our
movie high death
and actually all of them have been good
they've all been pretty good i'm not
going to say they're all four star
ratings but we haven't gotten any bad
reviews yet on the movie
and it's funny though because the first
review i ever got or one of the first i
ever got was in a print
magazine in fangoria and it was a very
bad review
and it broke my heart and at one level i
was thrilled to be in the magazine
on another level i was upset because
they hated the movie
and i think over time i've gotten more
and more
like i get less and less bothered by
reviews
i think the more stuff you make the more
movies you have out there
and you know the more frankly other
things you do with your time
you will care less about that i i think
you know every movie is going to have
its fans and its detractors
and you know you will not find one movie
that everybody loves
you know and you find plenty of movies
especially in the horror genre that
people love or hate so
you get less bothered by that over time
but it is always a little bit of a
suspense you you're putting when your
first reviews start rolling in and
you're like oh
see what people think you know
you